how about you give people an
introduction as to how you view
what the outer world is and what the
inner world is perhaps what led you to
that as well that distinction and also
the utility of the inner World which is
generally discarded
yes so
after World We I just mean the physical
leaders at least inhabit we sort of
study we it can be physics of what we're
talking about you know it can be planets
the stars and gravitational ways and
cosmological black holes it can be just
a tree outside my window up here and so
that all those those things and you know
they all seem jazz on laws and science
as incredibly successful in actually
finding many many of these laws and
understanding the why things happen in
the external world that we see
uh
but there also been kind of old
traditions which focused
much more on the inner world
and the problem there
was
not I mean
I'm talking about kind of the best
things that I have come across I'm not
talking about everybody so sure um so
the problem there was basically
um
not that the outer walls are of the
world and phenomena etc etc are not
important
but somehow
the central theme
should be
why is there suffering
and what would lead to lessening or
elimination of suffering
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy